we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here is a
voicemail criticizing me for a big faux
pas i made when talking about my urban
garden on stream yesterday take a listen
to this hello david i saw your show
today and i love you so you said today
that you were getting some you had your
raised beds built and you were bringing
in some dirt yes
and then you wondered if you should call
it soil dirt is what you wash off of
your hands and soil is live medium and
just waiting to grow your vegetables got
it thank you
yeah so i I clearly AM a beta male
gardener there I I don't pretend to be
an expert in gardening and I had when I
said that I was having dirt delivered to
grow vegetables my instinct was that
that wasn't the right term and indeed it
is not I am having a beautiful soil
delivery this weekend I'm going to plant
I'm in a much in the style of Howard
Dean we're gonna plant carrots and we're
gonna clamp peppers and we're gonna
plant tomatoes and we're going all the
way to the fall wooo with vegetables so
follow the adventure on Instagram at
David Pakman the planting starts very
soon the soil is imminently going to be
delivered and it's going to be very very
exciting and it is just something not
related to the virus which I think we
all desperately need right now don't
miss today's bonus show get instant
access to it by being a member or a
patron I'll talk to you then